patrick pbd everyone knows pat obviously
we're in his uh
in his his house
so he told a story uh on the pot on the
podcast a few uh weeks ago about that he
was speaking
at a school to 600 kids and he says
listen i run a youtube channel i'm also
a businessman entrepreneur and he's and
he asked the kids how many raise your
hand how many of you guys
uh grow up you want to be a youtuber he
goes 80 of the room
raised their hands so i said okay and
then some of these stats we're gonna
throw out there i said boom we have our
first topic so in a study published in
the sun i think this was like four or
five years ago in 2017 so we'll figure
out if things have changed 75 percent of
children ages 6 to 17
said that they want and they grow up
they want to become youtubers and social
media influencers exactly that was their
most desired career so do you think that
this was 2017 do you think that is a
higher now or lower now what do you
think higher even more why is it higher
with the way social media is running and
moving yeah when i go around when i go
to speak at schools and i ask kids what
they want to be yeah when they grow up
the number one response i get is
instagram famous insta-famous how about
you it's crazy for sure but that's but
that's the thing is even careers have uh
like fame to them so even if you want to
be a fireman there's a sexy ass fireman
influencer oh yeah there is what's his
name again
i feel like you're like a sexy
you got your little fireman outfit
finally you look like a fireman there
she is
so that is so you guys agree that even
uh five years ago this study 75 percent
of kids
said they wanted to be influencers
youtubers you think that number's even
higher definitely wait to hear these
stats and you'll see oh my god the money
that's being made people want to get
into this business